problema 5 al principio del 2010 un
contenedor tenía 1.400 toneladas de
residuos la función creciente w la
función creciente w modela el total
acumulado de residuos almacenados en el
contenedor los administradores estiman
que w satisface la ecuación diferencial
derivada de w con respecto al tiempo es
igual a un 25 hago de w menos 300 por
los siguientes 20 años donde w son
toneladas y t son las unidades de años
desde el 2010 inciso a usa la recta
tangente de las gráficas de w en el
tiempo igual a cero en el tiempo igual a
cero eso es importante para aproximar la
cantidad de residuo que tendrá el
contenedor después de los siguientes
tres meses es decir en el tiempo de
igual a un cuarto de igual a un cuarto
porque tres meses son un cuarto de año
bueno antes que nada quiero que se den
cuenta que nosotros no sabemos nada de w
w con respecto al tiempo la gráfica de w
realmente no sabemos nada más que la
ecuación diferencial de w que no nos
dice mucho al respecto de w por ahorita
al menos lo que sabemos es que w es una
función creciente entonces imagínense
que yo tengo aquí al a un plano
cartesiano en este plano cuando yo tengo
el eje de la w que empiezan en 400
toneladas y a partir de aquí es una
función creciente entonces esta es mi
función w este es el tiempo contra w de
hecho ahorita que lo veo voy a borrar un
poco esta función porque es lo que
necesito yo es la recta tangente a w en
el tiempo igual a un cuarto entonces voy
a hacer mejor esta gráfica como w y
ahora sí voy a dibujar la recta tangente
en el tiempo igual a cero va a ser esta
de verde
yo lo que quiero es la pendiente de la
recta tangente en el tiempo igual a cero
para aproximarla al tiempo igual a un
cuarto entonces quiero esta recta
tangente en el tiempo igual a un cuarto
quiero aproximar al tiempo igual a un
cuarto entonces si este es el tiempo
aquí tengo un cuarto y lo que yo voy a
querer hacer es agarrar la recta
tangente en el tiempo igual a cero para
aproximar al tiempo igual a un cuarto
eso es lo que voy a hacer a partir de
ahorita repito otra vez para que nos
quede más claro yo lo que quiero es la
pendiente de la recta tangente evaluada
en el tiempo igual a cero para darnos
una aproximación de qué es lo que pasa
en el tiempo igual a un cuarto entonces
yo creo que para esto voy a agarrar la
cosa el diferencial le voy a escribir de
otra manera de una manera que va a ser
mucho más amena para trabajar y que nos
va a dar o nos va ayudar a dar la
respuesta bueno pues darse cuenta que la
derivada de w con respecto al tiempo es
lo mismo que w prima de t y esto es
igual a un 25 de quien de www atentos
espacial w de t menos 300 y yo lo que
quiero es
evaluar la función derivada de w con
respecto al tiempo es decir w prima de t
en el tiempo igual a 0 o sea w prima de
0 entonces quién es w prima de 0 pues lo
voy a escribir aquí ya está muy fácil el
resolver este problema
wv prima de 0 es igual a un 25 por la
fórmula de derivada de w con respecto al
tiempo de w de zero que ya sabemos
cuánto es es 1400
menos 300 bien ahora voy a sustituir w 0
que es mil 400 toneladas vamos a
escribir los dobles prima de 0 o la
pendiente de la recta tangente evaluada
en 0 o la derivada evaluado en el tiempo
igual a 0 es igual a un 25 por 1.400
menos 300 que 1.400 menos 306 mil 100
entonces solamente habrá que
multiplicarlo por un mid xinhua por
dividido entre 25 que ya no hay tanta
dificultad
1100 entre 25 es lo mismo que 44 y con
esto acabo de encontrar la pendiente de
mi recta tangente en el tiempo igual a
cero entonces acabo de encontrar la
pendiente m es igual a 44 no mejor de
voy a poner el nombre pendiente es igual
a 44 y bueno de que me va a servir esta
pendiente para ayuda a aproximar mi
cantidad de residuo que voy a obtener en
el tiempo igual a un cuarto bueno tal
vez no se note muy bien aquí en mi
gráfica pero lo que voy a hacer es
intentar hacer una gráfica mejor para
que vean a qué me refiero con aproximar
en el tiempo igual a un cuarto entonces
voy a intentar hacer una mejor gráfica
estos son mis ejes aquí empiezo en 1400
estos viajes de w este es el eje del
tiempo y voy a intentar hacer una mejor
gráfica bien a lo mejor algo más
exagerado un bien y
a ver qué hacemos aquí esta es muy
gráfica w es una gráfica creciente y lo
que voy a hacer es fijarme en el tiempo
igual a un cuarto entonces al menos lo
que sé es que mi pendiente de mi recta
tangente en cero es igual a 44 entonces
está pendiente la tengo y supongamos que
aquí va a ser 1 y tener una pendiente de
44 quiere decir que si yo recuerdo una
unidad de tiempo mi recta va a aumentar
44 unidades en w pero yo no quiero en
una unidad de tiempo yo solamente quiero
en un cuarto entonces mi aproximación
tiene que ser mejor entonces qué voy a
hacer voy a tomarme que este es un medio
y entonces este es un cuarto y voy a ver
qué pasa con una aproximación en un
cuarto fíjense es esta la aproximación
que yo voy a tomar entonces darse cuenta
que mi recta tangente realmente sí se
parece mucho al valor que debería de
tener mi función entre igual a un cuarto
entonces déjenme escribir en la ecuación
de esta recta y la ecuación esta recta
es w
de aproximación w aproximado es igual a
44 que es la pendiente porque más en
donde corte en el eje de w o sea mil 400
w aproximado ya no puedo calcular en el
tiempo igual a un cuarto de estos y de a
44 no esperen mejor de que me ponerlo de
una manera más formal w aproximado en el
tiempo igual a un cuarto en un cuarto va
a ser igual a 44 por un cuarto más 1400
y ya están aproximación w aproximado de
un cuarto apenas y nueva caber ok 44 por
un cuarto es lo mismo que 11 entonces va
a ser 11 más 1.400 y esto es lo mismo
que mil 411 toneladas porque eso
estábamos viviendo en toneladas y pues
ya está ya tenemos una aproximación que
tal vez no sea el valor real pero es una
buena aproximación dado que un cuarto es
un punto muy cercano al cero entonces ya
tenemos una buena aproximación y la
respuesta del inciso a 1411 toneladas